it's Oscar time Sunday night Hollywood
will give famous people awards for what
they say are the best performances but
Oscars leave out political actors not
fair
politicians deceive people just like
actors do and some of their performances
deserve recognition if not Oscars at
least Stas ker so here are this year's
Stas Qura Ward's the Award for Best
Performance by a Richie leadest goes to
House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi in
her eagerness to trash Trump's tax cuts
she described thousand dollar bonuses as
crumbs crumbs that they are giving to
workers to kinda but the schmooze Owen
is so pathetic the award for Best
Performance by a Democrat goes to San
Francisco district attorney George
Gascon after California legalized weed
the DA promised to drop 3,000 marijuana
convictions and he made getting them
dropped easy on the poor guys sitting in
jail the process will take no hearings
people will not have to hire attorneys
that will never have to come to our
courts we believe that is the right
thing to do and it's a just thing to do
and speaking of doing the right thing
the stas Kerr for Best Performance by
the president goes to the moment when
President Trump said we have cut 22
burdensome regulations for every one new
rule great I wish you'd cut the new
rules too but I'll take what I can get
after all he also chose jeff Sessions to
be his attorney general and sessions
wins the Stas Kerr for worst praise for
government abuse for saying this about
asset forfeiture I love that program man
we had so much fun doing that and taking
the drug dealers money so much fun
taking billions of dollars from people
most of whom never even got a trial
that's a crime not good government yet
both parties like it and that isn't even
the worst example of bipartisanship we
have worked well together
the stas cur for the worst act of
bipartisanship goes to senators Chuck
Schumer and Mitch McConnell for their
budget deal this budget deal is the
first real sprout of bipartisanship I
particularly thank my friend the
Democratic leader I hope we can build on
this bipartisan momentum no please don't
you've already added billions to our
unsustainable debt and caught almost
nothing does any politician ever say no
to more government well yes one has Rand
Paul gets a Stas Kurt for best defense
of the Constitution
Paul demanded the NSA and FBI get
warrants before they spy on Americans do
we really want all of our phone calls
recorded and then have the ability of
the government to bring you in and ask
you questions about your phone calls and
if you're not perfectly accurate and
recording your phone calls you could go
to prison all we're asking for is that
for Americans the Constitution should be
in order but the Constitution bores
people so spying on Americans continues
next the Oscar for Best Democrat on free
speech goes to senator Elizabeth Warren
who after joining left wingers and
vilifying a conservative then said I
think it's dangerous to suppress speech
first suppression can backfire instead
of shutting up individuals with
disgusting views it becomes a launching
pad to national attention second
suppression suggests weakness
it makes us sound afraid like we're
afraid that we can't defeat evil ideas
with good ideas good point the way to
fight bad ideas is with good ideas
unfortunately her ideas are usually not
good ideas and that brings us to the
Stas Cerf for worst performance by a
prison n't that goes to narcissus no
wrong picture I meant President Trump
for bragging like a child and tweet
after tweet
don't misunderstand this Oscar judges
loved his tweeting but some are
repulsive
he's a genius he ended the assault on
Christmas and because he got strict on
commercial aviation there have been zero
deaths
give me a break he hasn't even done
anything that affected aviation finally
just as the Oscars give out one lifetime
achievement award this year's Stas kurz
conclude with an award to a politician
who consistently has fought for liberty
it's trillions of dollars congressman
Ron Paul has taken every opportunity he
can to challenge enemies of Liberty I
don't understand this division why you
may defend social Liberty and liberties
were rather well but as soon as it comes
to me spending my money on soon
responsibility he fought to limit
executive power why don't we just open
up the Constitution and read it you're
not allowed to go to war without a
declaration of war
and he fought the political
bipartisanship that's bankrupting
America and we've had way too much
bipartisanship for about 60 years
Ron Paul deserves several stas kurz for
fighting for freedom now my time is up
that's the Stas kurz for this year
you